hello and welcome everyone to pi data
boston's october meetup
for those of you don't know pi data is
an educational program of a non-profit
organization called num focus
the global pi data network promotes
discussion of best practices
new approaches and emerging technologies
for data management processing analytics
and visualization
we are a community of users and
developers of opens you
share ideas and learn from each other we
also approach data science using many
languages
including but not limited to python
julia and r
my name is anita yip and i'm one of the
co-organizers of pi data boston
i'm really excited to have mike woodward
here with us today
to talk about forecasting u.s
presidential elections
before we get to his talk i want to talk
about a few items
first feel free to introduce yourselves
in the chat and in slack
there's also an introduction channel on
slack and as we continue to hold these
virtual events we want to continue to
build our community
and of course if you have questions
during the presentation please unmute
yourself
and chime in for a real-time
conversation for those of you who aren't
speaking
please make sure to turn off your
microphones
[Music]
you can find us on our website
pidataboston.github.io
and on social media feel free to tweet
about today's talk using
pi database if you haven't joined our
slack community
yet please do so and this information is
all in our meetup page as well
now i'll announce some upcoming events
first
pi data global is happening from
november 11th to
the 15th this premier global data
science conference will be held online
for the first time
it's five days packed with talks
tutorials
posters open source sprints and a
digital hallway track
so check out the website at
global.pidata.org for more info
next pi data boston is holding a set of
talks on wednesday november 18th
from 7 to 9 pm first we'll hear
from angela vujick on brain computer
interfaces
and she'll presenting a tutorial on how
to interface with the open bci
using python and useful python libraries
for electrophysiology
afterwards austin avito and ukar litter
will deliver a talk on explainable
workflows using python
focusing on skills and tactics used to
help data scientists articulate their
findings to end users
stakeholders and other scientists we
hope you'll be able to join us then as
well
as of all meetings we want to reiterate
that pi data is dedicated to providing a
harassment free
experience for everyone please behave
professionally as we do not tolerate
harassment in any form
you can view the longer version of our
code of conduct at this website
feel free to reach out to any of the
organizers if you have any concerns
and thank you for helping making this a
welcoming community
for all of us
lastly these meetings are only made
possible with the help of volunteers
you can do anything from organizing an
event by recruiting speakers
to creating partnerships when we're back
to meeting in person you might also help
secure venues and food
what's more you can volunteer to present
and speak at one of our meetings
you don't have to have a full talk ready
when you fill out the speaker form as
the organizing team can help you through
it
currently we have one opening in
december for our medium length talk
and we'll be especially interested in a
talk on machine learning model or how
you might be leveraging machine learning
models
and as always we have an ongoing need
for speakers in january and beyond
mike actually was someone who filled out
the google form on our meetup page
expressing interest in speaking so i
reached out back in june
mike finished the bulk of his talk uh in
august and then we made this event
happen
so i'm really excited to hear more from
mike about this timely topic
and with that i'll turn it over to mike
to start presenting
okay thank you uh let's i'll just
share my screen just bear with me a
second oh
sorry i've ha can you see my screen can
you guys see where it says forecasting
us presidential elections
yes excellent wonderful thank you so for
those of you who have maybe mistakenly
tuned in and think you're going to see a
presentation about people gyrating
around polls beautiful people doing it
you're not going to see that you're
going to be very disappointed
but for those of you who have tuned in
expecting a presentation about
u.s presidential elections hopefully
you'll be less disappointed by what
you're about to hear
okay let's uh talk a little bit about
what i'm going to talk about over the
next
few minutes next uh 45 minutes or so
i'm going to talk about what went wrong
in 2016.
but i'm also going to use my experiences
as an opinion poll street interviewer to
give some
insight into what went wrong and i'm
going to talk about what it's really
like
to be an opinion pollster on the street
in my case
i'm then going to change tact and have a
look at a
election modeling and this is where
we're going to get into some more
statistics
and modeling of data and what's going on
and
also i'm going to let you into some
secrets about why some forecasters have
got things
badly wrong i'll explain where in their
models they've got it wrong and then
what we can do to get it right
that's going to be more mathematical
very briefly i'm going to touch on data
sources if this is the kind of thing
that you want to do yourself i'm going
to point you where you can get the data
i'm going to show you the model that
i've got working
now for those of you who are python
programmers or working in a python
environment and who are interested in
business intelligence apps
using python what i'm going to show you
is in effect
a business application written using
python 100
python no other language and i'll show
you this i'll give you a demonstration
of how it works so you get a sense of
what's actually possible
then i'm going to explain how the model
was put together and some of the
architecture and some of the
techniques i've used to build the model
quickly and hopefully those will be
of interest to you for those of you who
are python programmers and looking at bi
apps and that kind of stuff finally
we'll wrap up and i'll talk about some
lessons learned and some other places
where we can apply this technology
that i'm going to talk about so if you
want to dive deeper into this
this session is being recorded i'll make
the slides available if you care about
the slides
uh i've also maintained a blog which is
mostly about management
and statistics but what i've done in my
blog over the last
couple of weeks is i've blogged a lot
about a lot of the topics that i'm
talking about tonight and i provide more
details
including academic references you know
references to papers that kind of stuff
as well
so today on my blog i posted a summary
blog which is kind of a greatest hits of
all the election stuff i've posted
so you can find all the election stuff
that i've done in one convenient place
and the source code to the project that
i'm going to show you that actually
shows the general uh
the presidential election and the
forecasting and the charts and all the
rest of it
that's all available on gitlab or rather
on github
uh if you could just follow the links
there in the chat
i've put links through to the github
site and to
my blog as well and a couple of other
bits and pieces if you're interested
all right so let me give you a little
bit about my background
a long time ago and i won't tell you how
long ago but quite a long time ago
i worked for a market research company
in the uk
it was a well-known market research
company an opinion polling company
uh it's active in the united states i
think it's a us company
and i was the street interviewer right
now in the opinion poll hierarchy that's
basically the lowest life form right the
lowest bottom of the rung of the
opinion poll hierarchy so i was sent out
on the streets with a clipboard to go
and ask people questions
and that's where i learned the big
lesson that i learned is that random
sampling
does not exist right despite what the
textbooks tell you that
it just doesn't exist at all let me give
you an example very quick example
i was doing a political opinion poll and
i needed a
male in the rage age range 20 to 25 and
i'll talk about quotas in a minute
and i saw two men coming towards me on
the street now one was a typical
college student looking person and the
other one was
a skinhead in full skinhead clothing
right now if you imagine you know i'm a
bit weedy frankly
right and imagine standing on a street
corner with a
clipboard and you've got one of these
two men to interview which one would you
approach
now obviously survival instincts in kind
of some
frankly what was a bit of a tougher area
of london you know i i made my decision
but that's introducing bias so every day
when you're out in the streets
interviewing people there is bias about
who you interview and who do you not
so there's bias about times when you
interview people so the people out in
the streets at seven o'clock are
different from the people at
midday are different from the people at
five o'clock who returns
different from the people at 11 o'clock
at night also where do you interview
them
if you interview people outside of the
library you'll get one set of answers
outside a school you'll get a different
set of answers and maybe outside the
factory gates a different set of answers
now to counter that kind of selection
bias which is conscious or unconscious
opinion poll companies give their
interviewers quotas
and these typically demographic
breakdowns of the population of the area
that you're interviewing in
so for example in a constituency um
in a parliamentary constituency in the
uk you might have a breakdown from the
census bureau
and it would be well for this kind of
sample size you'd expect so many males
of these age ranges different age ratios
so many females of this
age range maybe some income levels maybe
some
ethnicity pieces whatever they'll be
various criteria
that you'll select between sometimes
depending on the poll there will be
other
criteria as well that are important
but and this is going to come back when
we talk about what happened to 2016
but each question that you ask costs
time and money each question that you
ask
about qualifying the responses right
each of those questions
could meet with a refusal and every
additional question that you ask
is likely to upset some more people so
for example if i ask you
are you who are you going to vote for
you might well tell me but then if i say
well can you tell me your age range
can you tell me where you live can you
tell me your income level
right and the list goes on and on and
eventually you're going to get very fed
up and you'll find my questions
intrusive
so opinion pollsters know this and they
try to restrict the number of questions
to
just the ones that are relevant right to
get a representative sample
note that i didn't say a random sample
nowadays people have gone from
being um from street interviewing to
basically the phone and the internet
because they're cheaper
but the problems are still there they've
just become a little bit more subtle if
you like but they're still there
but the point i want to leave you with
before we get on to talking about 2016
is that random sampling for opinion
polls
does not exist all right and that each
opinion poll company
has their own methodology for sampling
and that introduces bias
now they try and make the bias as small
as possible they're continually tweaking
their algorithms
but each opinion company has their own
set of biases and that's going to come
into
that will be very important later on
when we start looking at error models
right by the way if you want to ask
questions you can always unmute yourself
and ask and i'm happy to take questions
as we go along
all right so let's talk about 2016 and
what happened
and bottom line sampling sampling
sampling was the problem in 2016.
so where it went right was obviously
forecasting the national vote
but that's not how us elections are
decided
where it went wrong was at the state
level right now subsequent to the 2016
election the american association for
public opinion research
and pew research did a study to try and
find out
what went wrong now the obvious point is
what went wrong so you don't do it again
so there's a couple of things that
they'd looked at and one thing i do want
to talk about
is this concept of the shy trump voter
what they said is that there was this
concept that trump voters
were somehow shy in retiring and
wouldn't admit to
pollsters that they actually intended to
vote for trump
now pew research when they did their
research said that they found no
evidence for this whatsoever
and i've heard of this idea in the uk
this a shy tory voter concept
utter nonsense right as it turns out
there's
very limited support for it it tends to
be something
that the losers like because it gives
them a sense of feeling superior
right because if you voted for the
losing party for the
uh winning party there must be something
wrong with you well
not really no and it's not really an
effect so you may have heard about the
idea of
shy trump photos in reality it's just
not a factor at all
two factors were important in 2016.
so one was education in previous
elections
uh the effective election or rather
educational level on people's voting
behavior was
minimal but in 2016 it was not
and in 2016 it showed a very distinct
bias
right now what happened is in the
opinion polls that took place in 2016
they did not include education as a
factor
to basically give representative samples
they didn't do it
because they tried to minimize the
number of questions that they asked the
qualifying questions
so that's the reason why they didn't
include it that turned out to be a very
important factor in 2016 and what i've
heard
for 2020 is that education is being
included
the other thing that was very different
or in 2016 is there appear to be a late
change in voter
preferences so you can see that in the
national vote data as well very clearly
a swing towards trump in the national
vote data but at the state level the
opinion polling stopped
before the election so voted changes
that took place in the last week or even
the last few days
weren't captured at the state level
polls right and that's why those polls
got it wrong
and if you look at the data about you
know how many polls got it wrong and for
how many states it's between five and
seven states in 2016 depending on
exactly how you count it
right but this concept of the polls
getting it wrong before
isn't new so in the uk general elections
there's been a couple of them where the
opinion pollsters have got it
very badly wrong the causes there have
been
sampling again right they didn't do
proper random sampling
turnout models as well so it turns out
that the left wing and the right wing
turn out to vote at different rates
right the right wing tend to be very
enthusiastic and get out of bed and vote
and the left-wing
tend to stay in bed or watch tv or
whatever it is they do but but don't
vote
um uk also had a problem with herding
which is where opinion polls let's
imagine it's a phenomena that's been
seen in the us but less so
so let's imagine that you have 10
opinion polls and they all say that
candidate a
has got 55 percent of the vote and
you're working for an opinion poll
company and your poll suggests that
instead
candidate a is 45 now that makes your
poll
an outlier makes you stick out and you
might well be correct
but the uk pollsters what happened is
that some of the results were suppressed
some of the outlying results were
suppressed and they changed some of
their methodologies to fall more in line
with the other pollsters
which meant collectively they moved as a
herd and unfortunately they moved in the
wrong
direction and you can read the reports
about this and about why exactly they
got it wrong
in the u.s there's also a history of
election failures as well polling
election failure some spectacular ones
uh one thing i do recommend everybody
who's involved in data science i
recommend that you
look at the story of what happened at
the literary digest
okay that was a fantastically large poll
the largest one of the largest opinion
polls i've ever heard of
orders of magnitude bigger than anything
that i've seen
done recently but it got it hopelessly
wrong
and what that proves is the size isn't
everything okay if your sampling
methodology isn't right
no matter what the size of your data set
is you're going to get the wrong answer
okay to uh the pew research and aapor
smith had a question about how did they
find out that education was a big factor
if
the data wasn't collected in the first
place oh one of the things that you can
do is go back
right in some cases data was collected
at this at the time in other cases you
can go back
and re-interview voters so for example
a lot of surveys actually ask for the
names and addresses of respondents and
that's one thing that i had to do
right as an opinion pollster partly
because they wanted to prove that i'd
actually talk to these people so i could
get my money
so in most cases or in a lot of cases
they do have names addresses of people
and you can do subsequent callbacks
after the election to figure out what
happened
now this is not everybody and not
everybody gives you an address
but if you can get enough you can
attempt some correlation
the other piece is that in every
election
every opinion poll organization uses
slightly different sampling techniques
and occasionally they will use education
or other factors as well and you can
just about glean enough data
to look at it so it's not an exact
science there is a big margin of error
on this
but you can actually do that most
opinion pulses do actually have the
names and addresses of p
and the phone numbers of people that
they spoke to so they can attempt to
call back
of course how many people choose to talk
to them later you know the non-response
issue is a problem
but at least they do have that data set
did i answer that question
okay i'm going to assume that that i did
okay okay thank you all right
so let's talk about opinion poll models
this is where we get to the statistics
part of the evening
so let's talk about what does not work
right every four years we have a spate
of these models that don't work
i'll give you an example right a lot of
them are based on
fundamentals or heuristics or whatever
in 2012 there was a great example two
political science professors
colorado university at boulder produced
a study and they looked at i think it
was gdp
and inflation and unemployment and a
whole bunch of other factors
and they forecast basically a romney
landslide
okay they were very confident at their
model because they'd looked back
and they selected all these factors and
they'd looked back 50 years or so
or a long time anyway and they'd seen
that the
you know these every election these
factors have pointed in a particular
direction and in 2012
they felt it would point in the same
direction but sadly for them
it did not so these type
of heuristic based or fundamental based
models have an absolutely dire a
diabolical
track record right they're absolutely
useless at forecasting
there's a book here if you want to read
a book about useless ways of forecasting
this book that's on the screen by ray
fair
is a great read he talks about how these
models have developed
and he starts from a relatively simple
model and then it gets it wrong and they
add in another factor
and it gets it right and then it gets it
wrong then they add in another factor
so gradually over time you can see that
these models get bigger and bigger and
bigger as they're adding in
more factors right to account for the
the variability in the data that they're
seeing
one of the factors that they added in
was a thing called
electability which is a numeric number
uh that they
somehow decide that one candidate is
more electable than another
and unfortunately the way that this
worked is that they allocated the number
after the election result was known
so again not very helpful
so for those of you who've done a lot of
mathematical modelling you know that
this this approach just isn't good
right it's just not sound scientifically
and that's been known for a very very
long time
um it falls the post-hoc fallacy is just
huge here and there's spurious
correlations
all over the place and uh in england we
call things where you choose a number of
fudge factor and there's loads and loads
of fudge factors in these models as well
so
it's just really not very deterministic
really
not very sound as a modelling approach
technically it's just abysmal
uh to ray fair's credit though he does
say in his book that there's absolutely
no evidence that voters when they go to
the polling booths
actually bet any of these factors in
mind
so what you have is a case where you're
building a model based on fundamentals
where
there's no evidence at all the voters
actually care about the things that are
in your model
it's not a good place to be modelling
now i would have said that these are no
good as priors
however i do believe based on what i've
seen recently that nate silva is using
some of these factors as priors as well
and factoring into his calculations
he's the only one who's seen his model
or other people in his company so i
can't tell you for sure
but reading his blog posts i i believe
that somehow he factors in some of these
these concepts of gdp and inflation and
unemployment and other things
but this concept about you know the
post-doc fallacy and taking a bunch of
factures and then using them
you know see how they were correlated in
the making of forecast it's a zombie
idea that will not die
and every four years these ideas pop up
again and again
really they're worth nothing so
if these things are worth nothing what
is and what does work
well poll aggregation all right so
the idea is that polling captures all of
the factors that people care about when
they go to vote
so you're not asking them do they think
about gdp or inflation or whatever else
it is you're asking them
how do you intend to vote in a week's
time a month's time
whatever it is for the modeling work i'm
going to show you
it focuses on state polls right
and uh what we do not all states have
polls in places which are very strongly
republican or very strongly democratic
they don't tend to be polls i mean why
would you bother running opinion polls
in wyoming but you know it's a very
republican state
the same thing for alaska and the same
thing for hawaii and washington dc as
well
there really isn't much point running an
opinion poll for example in washington
dc because it's just ridiculously
democratic right and the same thing for
for wyoming and the republican states as
well in those cases as a prior
uh we use the prior election results
so so who's doing this modeling well
obviously nate silver here who
is the king of forecasters his model the
reason why he did better in 2016
than the others is he had a more
sophisticated error handling
and i'm going to talk about that in a
second uh error handling is what
took down a lot of models in 2016
including the model that i had at the
time
um sam wang who is a professor of
neuroscience at princeton
whose kind of hobby is analyzing
elections
he produced a model and his model
included
um well it didn't include proper error
handling as i'll talk about in a second
however i've got to say that my model
originally started off by taking his
model which
he very generously gives the source code
for i
but it's diversion a lot since then but
the general approach that i'm taking is
is largely due to samwan but the way
that he models his errors
gives a way way over certain result and
i'm going to talk about error handling a
lot more in the next slide or so
the track record of these uh forecasts
is good
sort of uh in 2008 these models
correctly predicted every state all of
the states in the union
in 2012 every state was correctly
forecast
and 2016 well it didn't work out so good
right
and largely it didn't work out so good
because the state level polls were off
for reasons i've already discussed
so let's talk about more about the
mathematic world more about the process
of doing this so this is how these poll
aggregation models tend to work
so you start off with your previous
election results as your prior and in
some cases they will be your forecast
for states without
state level opinion polls you'll take
your state level opinion polls
and do clean up there is a ton of
cleanup to be done
so if you want to play around with this
data even if you get it from nate silva
or some of the other
aggregators you're going to still have
to do a ton of cleanup yourself
right and in fact for the model i'm
going to show you the code i'm going to
show you
i've had to do a lot of manual cleanup
of the data there's just
no way of automating it so you go
through you load those models
the idea is that you take those state
models and you produce an aggregate pole
model
from the aggregate pole model you can
work out a
probability of victory for each
candidate so for trump and biden you can
work out a probability of them winning
that state
right what's important here is the error
model and on the next slide we'll get
into error models in more detail
but the error model really impacts the
probability of victory
okay i'll say more about that later but
once you've got a probability of victory
for both candidates for every single
state
you can combine them and produce an
electoral college model
the electoral college model you can
there's 538 electoral college votes up
for grabs
not every combination is possible and
you can win between zero and 538
electoral college votes
the last thing we do here is actually
display the data in a way that's
consumable by users to make a
a forecast of where the electoral
college stands right now
according to the model and then you can
have a look at a state by state basis
and some other bits and pieces as we'll
see
an incorrect error model will lead to
great overconfidence and another point i
have to make here is that maine and
nebraska use a slightly different
election method from the other states
uh all of the other states use winner
take all uh maine and nebraska use
congressional congressional district
model
so in a more sophisticated version of my
model i take that into account but
i don't in this more basic version
all right error models and um
state level modelling so for those of
you who remember your statistics and
normal distributions
this top equation is really what's
governing the probability of victory for
a candidate
so d is the spread between candidates
so for example in a state like
massachusetts
biden is ahead of trump by about 20 or
20
plus that gives us a d of about uh 0.2
right so if we're going to work out for
a state like massachusetts what the
probability of
biden winning it is we can take d as
being point two
uh we can work out the uh the
standard deviation for the polls and
i'll talk about that a little bit later
and from that we can work out a
probability of biden winning
massachusetts or trump winning wyoming
or or whatever else it is
there is this is a standard uh equation
derived very simply from the nomination
and probability theory
but there are or rather are huge
problems
with it so the big problem is
it gives you way way over certain
results
it assumes random sampling which i've
already told you doesn't exist
so it assumes random sampling but once
you get past
a spread of one or two percent this
equation the top equation starts to give
you probabilities of winning for the
candidate of
90 plus so very quickly
if you can maintain a small lead it
gives you a really high certainty of
results
so a lot of books and courses give you
variations of this equation or
graphical representations of it a lot of
those books and courses are
wrong and uh to be to his credit i'm
going to give a call out to raphael
irizarry i'm sorry i've probably
mispronounced his name here
who is a great book a free book that
talks about election theory and election
modeling who gets it right
and he's doing a course on data science
and one of the courses actually includes
a lot of stuff on election modeling
and he gets it right as well and this
equation that i've called out below
actually comes from his course
so what he's saying here is uh if you're
working out the
spread for a candidate well it's not
actually the spread that you measure
right
there's the spread that you measure plus
a
uh an election bias plus a house bias
plus obviously a random error right
that's going on
these two things are missing from a lot
the house bias and the general election
bias are missing from most analysis
they're missing from sam wang's analysis
but nate silva i believe from what he's
written actually includes them
and you can attempt a analysis of the
magnitude of these errors
right from from the opinion polling data
right it's a little bit difficult to do
but you can do it
so this gives you a much much higher
level of uncertainty
than the random sample only in fact my
suspicion is
that if you probably took into account
the systemic bias
and other bits and pieces as well you
probably end up with a margin of error
twice that of what the poles are
counting rather what the poles are
saying
so the other problem or the other
feature of this type of model is
that the median or rather the mean
values of these
uh errors or biases is not zero so for
random sampling
the mean bias is zero but it is not for
some of these other effects as well and
that couples into the
error analysis in quite complicated ways
so um a couple of other things that this
first equation
doesn't take into account and i know
that most election models don't take
into account
is turnout effects right rather
so i've already said that the left wing
turnout
less frequently than the right wing that
kind of modelling as well is just not in
this equation at all
um don't knows and won't says isn't
included here
so let me give you an example of two
different elections
so one election uh the candidate it's 45
for one candidate 55 for another and the
spread between them is
is 10 to 0.1 for d so you can work out
an election victory right they're
probably very certain for the candidate
of 55
but then imagine another election where
one candidate is on 15 percent and the
other candidate is on
five and the remaining eighty percent of
the voters are undecided
there is a ten percent spread there as
well
which means that according to the first
equation
right the candidate in the lead has the
same chance as winning in the 15
5 cases in the 40 rather 5545 case
plainly that's not right so it doesn't
take into account
don't know someone says now as a kind of
point
for this election the number of don't
knows is actually very low it seems as
if in the 2020 election most people have
made up their mind frankly
wasn't the case in 2016 but it is the
case in 2020
the number of don't knows is
historically low
so how do you combine opinion polls
now this is where things where i diverge
from the textbooks a lot and where the
textbooks get it
wrong as well so the naive case for
textbooks is to say well
what we're going to do is if we're
combining two opinion polls we'll just
take the mean
of them or if we're combining three or
four polls we'll take the mean
that is wrong right if you start playing
around
with opinion polling data you'll see
it's almost the definition of a data set
with large outliers
outliers absolutely all over the place
right uh
for this for this model rather for this
technology so the mean isn't an
appropriate way
uh weighted median by size is probably a
better choice
a lot of the books talk about the
combination of errors and the
uncertainty using an equation like the
one here i've shown you
but the reality is of course that's
assuming
random sampling which i've told you
doesn't exist and
the biases for each opinion poll
organization are different
because they're all using their
different methodologies so you can't
combine them
in that kind of naive way and again as
i've said
the biases don't have a mean value of
zero either
right so you have to be careful how they
propagate
the reality the problem with these
results and it was a problem with my
model in 2016 is it gives way way over
certain results if you follow the
textbook methodology
textbook methodology causes you to
shrink your uncertainty uh shrink your
margin of error
and it gives you this you know a
combination even if you use median right
you end up with a
way way over certain result so my choice
for this election was to simplify things
a lot in my
later situation of my model i took
a seven-day window rather than the
10-day window that i took before it's a
rolling window
what i do for each state is take all of
the opinion polls that occurred in that
state in that rolling window
rank them by spread right so it can be
in favor of the democratic candidate or
the republicans candidate doesn't really
matter
you choose one you rank them by spread
and i choose the median poll
and i take the error for that poll i'm
still not
properly taking into account things like
bias
for example house bias or election bias
but for right now that gives me a higher
level of uncertainty than i had in my
previous model
so that is it's not the most
sophisticated way forward
but it works and it gives me a shorter
window so i should be able
to capture late breaking changes
right now how this works in terms of
working out an electoral college model
so what i'm able to do for each state
and for each candidate is work out a
probability of victory
so for biden i can work out probability
of victory for every state and for trump
i can work out a probability of
victory for each state and using the
generator polynomial
so i won't go back and explain what that
is that's back to your probability
theory classes
i can work out probably a probability
distribution
covering all 538 electoral college votes
right and what i end up with is a
distribution for each candidate
by day right so i can see how the race
evolves and i'll show you a
demonstration of that a bit later so
using this technique i can get
basically my electoral college model
right
so some vulnerabilities for this
uh actually doing the data cleanup is is
pretty tough
right this is not the easiest data set
in the world to clean up
you're having to look at the polls and
figure things out and figure out what's
going on
there tends to be multiple iterations of
opinion polls with slightly different
factors
but you only want one but which one do
you include is difficult
i'm making the assumption that the
closer we get to the election the more
polls there are which is
mostly true i said my error model
doesn't really it doesn't include house
bias although i've tried to minimize
my um my exaggerated my minimization of
errors
don't know someone's says aren't
included 2016 2020 not really a problem
but i really have to do something about
that for another election
and maine and nebraska who's in the
congressional district model i don't
have that in this model i assume that
winner takes all
so for the polls as well late changes in
voter intent at the state level may well
still
mess things up right you're relying on
your underlying data there's nothing
that you can do about that
if there are systemic biases across
pollsters as there were in 2016
it'll be very difficult to get that
again education is unlikely to be a
problem in this election
uh because if they're all aware of it
and correcting for it but there could be
some other factor
that we don't know about that we find
after the election was a factor
and it could also changes in the voter
population as well so this is
largely related to turnout as well i
heard in 2016 that the african-american
turnout was lower
uh the white rural turnout was higher
i've heard i don't know if that's true
but it's possible that you've got
changes in voter populations and
relative
changes in turnout levels depending on
the election very hard to model
so again those are vulnerabilities of
this approach
right now for those of you who would
like to do this yourself and you want to
play around with the data
there's some data sources here to get
your data originally i got my data in 20
2016 from the pollster api
but that's bit in the dust sadly right
now i'm getting my data from nate silva
and 538 and he makes available all of
his polling data which is
really great for him to do so uh real
clear politics
offers an api as well which i've kicked
around with in the past
uh which i've also heard is okay but
realistically if you're doing this
yourself you have to get the data
through an aggregator there's just just
no way that you can
get the opinion polling data yourself
it's just not going to happen it's too
difficult
so it has to come to an aggregator
okay so it's time to do a little
software demo
so i'll show you how this works
right uh okay
guys can you see uh can you see my
screen can you see a picture of the
white house
okay wonderful thank you all right so
this is the application
it's called silkworm for reasons i won't
go into it's entirely
written in python all right every single
line is in python
so let's go to the manage data tab i can
have a look at the data that's in the
system
i have the electoral college allocations
i have the previous presidential results
in the system though not all of them
and in this case i've just got 2020 data
in the system for today's demonstration
uh i've got 2016 data hanging around and
2012 data as well
which i'll include but this gives you a
sense you can actually look at different
elections pull the data in do different
sorts of analysis
uh run load forecast right so i won't
run the forecast i've run it earlier it
just takes about a minute to run because
of the amount of data
but i'm going to load what i analyzed
previously today
so now i've loaded up the 2020 forecast
models
and i can have a look at the vote
forecast by time
so this is the money shot i'll just make
this a little bit bigger so you guys can
see
so along the x-axis date and the y-axis
is electoral college votes
and this is the 270 to win line and as
you can see
it's forecasting my model is for
unsurprisingly maybe
so most of you tuned in it's forecasting
a
large democratic victory okay so if i
just hover over we'll see what it's
saying
okay right now the latest model is
forecasting 374
electoral college votes for biden and
164 for trump
you can see how it's changed over time
some of these large flips
are where you get um states that are
flipping i think this one large one
might be florida
i'm not sure but you can see some of the
other states as the states flip
so you don't get an even model what
happens is in the polling data as as you
consider a poll flipping from one
candidate to another
you see these discontinuities in the
chart
i want to also point out to you that
apart from
back in march there was no time where
trump has been
in the lead according to this model
right
um and you can see a few cases where
it's dipped down but you can also see
you can see something about the
direction that this is heading as well
right so we can look at the electoral
college vote forecast
so this is the distribution between 0
and 538 electoral college seats this is
a probability distribution function
and we can see is a different
probabilities right so the democratic
candidate
and the republican candidate we can see
that not all probabilities
are possible right there's some
combination of electoral college seats
which are
just not possible but here we can
see the way you know the way it's
working out we can see that different
combinations
you could see that my previous chart
showed you an electoral college forecast
but had things been ever so slightly
different you could see it would jump
around between these different peaks
right and there's not much in it between
these peaks right
but note that there's almost no overlap
here right it's my model is clearly
favoring biden
but i have to say in 2016 my model
clearly favored clinton as well
so let's go back and i'll move a slider
so we can have a look and see how this
probability distribution
changed for different days
there are a few questions in the chat
right now yeah
first is from adam on is that landslide
what we're anticipating i'm assuming the
landslide for
voting democratic yes from the previous
okay
and then landon asked how would you
model the election results on
november 3rd in the event that the
supreme court contests male
imbalance wow um
that's really hard the opinion polls
just don't capture that that would have
to be something outside of this model
right um bearing in mind the
questions that people are asked i think
some are asking about how people intend
to vote
i haven't seen much uh i've seen some of
that going on in the opinion polls but
not enough to draw any kind of
conclusions
so you'd have to you'd have to develop
some kind of model for what would happen
so that's an election model based on
mail-in votes
difficult to do actually could we hold
on to that thought as well because i
want to talk about electoral fraud at
the end and there's some pieces tying
into that
i think because we could talk about
electoral fraud and that as well
so london could you come back and ask
that question a bit later uh
okay and then there are a few more
questions oh wow okay
uh so joy asked can you show the 2016
prediction
uh i could but not tonight because i
haven't loaded it into the model
unfortunately um so my screenshots were
a little bit like this they were less
certain
the results were a lot closer in 2016. i
still had clinton having a convincing
victory i had her winning
uh pennsylvania michigan and wisconsin
right
so and i think there was an i think
maybe north carolina as well
so my model was still out it was still
favoring clinton as well right
so the question is is obviously is my
model
wrong again and it could well be bearing
in mind i'm relying on the underlying
polling data to be correct and it was
wrong in those states
if and only if those pollsters have
correctly
uh addressed the education issue will
this model be reliable
if they've got it wrong right then
this model is going to be wrong as well
all i can tell you
is that for 2018 the pollsters and i'm
looking at the same cost of data
for 2018 when they were forecasting the
results of the 2018 election largely the
pollsters got it right
and this time they they did include uh
education
so there is some recent track record but
always
so you know with all of these models you
have to take them with a pinch of salt
because there could be a factor that has
not been included
right and the pollsters could get it
wrong and bearing in mind that's why i
was at paints to point out about the uk
example as well
the pollsters have got it wrong in
previous elections uh they've got it
wrong in other countries as well
so please don't take this as being
certainty it is a model
and it could well be wrong based on the
underlying data
kirsten also had a follow-up question on
the 2016
prediction she said you you said 2016
polling stock weeks before the election
was your model based on that data or did
you have access to data
up until the election okay no i just
used the uh
so i used the data i used for 2016. in
fact okay
let me take a step back if you go to my
github page and you poke around you'll
find the 2016 data and one of the things
that i have to do
is make that a little bit more easily
available
right so the 2016 data i got from the
pollster api
those were active then nate silver
wasn't so active at least in terms of
making the data
available in 2016. i got the latest
opinion polling data from
uh the pollster api and i got it when it
was published
the problem in 2016 is that a lot of the
state-level
polling stopped a week or so before the
election
now this time apparently they have
promised that they will continue but
bear in mind the pollsters need money
right people are paying for these
opinion polls so if the organizations
that are paying for the opinion polls
don't want to pay for a last-minute
opinion poll it probably won't happen
right so that that's one of the issues
with this as well that
um you know if you look at where the
funding's coming from for opinion polls
it's from newspapers
right newspapers and other sources as
well
if they decide that they can't be
bothered with it or the elections have
done deal
they won't pay for a last-minute polling
so that is still a vulnerability in this
model as well
i think one of the ways of capturing
whether there's a last minute swing is
to look at the national polling results
which is not in this model at all
some models have a correction at the
state level for national pieces
and you could probably attempt some
correction for a last-minute swing based
on national data
but i don't do it in this model
and john had a question also on uh in
the uk
opinion polling tables give you
breakouts
um demographic breakouts specifically
like by age gender
education location did you have these
breakouts available in 2016 in the us
or is it a case of it being available
but trapped in a pdf
prison like in the uk polls wow john
you are dead right yes it is trapped in
a pdf prison you can
get the data out in fact um
i'll take a little digression to tell
you a story right so the kind of data
that john is
is talking about is crosstabulation data
and
it's data that again you can see the
demographic breakdown for what they
actually
measured right the idea is that
according to the american association of
public opinion research
and and sorry the acronym is awful but
anyway according to their rules that
pollsters must keep that data and they
must make it available
and a lot of pollsters do but some do
not
um a lot of the data that's polling data
is made available is in pdfs
which is why i talked about having an
aggregator to pull that data out right
the aggregators don't pull out the cross
tabulation data
election polling fraud has been
committed
and it has been committed by companies
and they've been caught out because they
haven't made the cross-tabulation data
available
or when they have made the
cross-tabulation data available it's
clearly indicated fraud
okay and on my blog i actually talk
about a couple of cases where
fraud was found through that data but
yeah john you're right it's just really
difficult to get that data
and the aggregators don't pull it out
and it i mean
in effect it's impossible for a hobbyist
like me to pull that out
the level of effort is just too great
so a few more questions okay let's go in
a lot of interest
um so one of the questions was are you
able to generate a 95
prediction interval as an example or
just point estimates
ah yes so i am a and you will see that
when i go to the other
um tabs in this uh this application
i was going to put a 95 confidence
interval on this chart right
but then when i looked at this
distribution i realized i'd have to give
a bit of a think
about what that meant right and how i
would actually work out what the 95
confidence interval was right so it's
not as straightforward as it appears to
be
so so yes you could do that uh you've
got the data to do it in fact to put the
95 percent confidence interval on you'd
have to use this data
all right just not exactly sure of the i
haven't given it enough thought to how
to use it
bearing in mind the nature uh and
there's some if
let's go and find a recent place where
it gets a bit crazy
okay something like this i mean someday
some of the results are a little bit
hard to figure out what the 95
percent confidence interval would look
like but in principle it's possible to
do it and in some of the other charts
that i'll show you a bit later i have
done it
on a related note uh eric mentioned that
370 would imply biden wins in ohio
and georgia or texas that scenario is a
little
in front of 538 and gelman and others in
the economist
how do you quantify confidence in your
prediction
right so so that those are good
questions right um
there's a couple of things i use a
shorter time window
right i use a seven day window one of
the problems with that window is it's
subject to fluctuations which we'll see
in uh when i'll show you a couple of
tabs you can see that some of the
results
in fact if you remind me of those two
states when i show you at the state
level results we can have a closer look
at
when you look at my model is more
susceptible to flipping because of that
and the reason why i've
shortened the time window is because i
wanted to capture last minute
changes in voter behavior the problem
with doing that is your model is is more
susceptible to changes
as well right so yes in the state level
models i will show you and i will show
you the 95
confidence intervals for those models as
well
great that was all the questions so far
okay all right we'll come back to that
please don't if i don't answer the
questions later with what's coming up in
some of the tabs
let me know all right so i showed you
the distribution on the daily
basis let's have a forecast by geography
which i think
just been asked so you can see the
states actually i'll go back to the
beginning
right so the data set starts in january
2020.
now what happens in january 2020 is that
the data is dominated by the previous
election results
and as more polls come in right you can
oh
sorry you can as more polls come in you
can see the results settling down a
little bit
right i'll just move this along
right so you can see here's ohio i
actually have ohio as a
dead heat right so it might the way that
it might work out in my model is it
might flip to biden i'm not entirely
sure how it copes with dead heats
actually
because it doesn't occur that often i
forget what was the other state that he
mentioned oh georgia
yeah i i have georgia going uh for biden
by about a percentage point
but again it's probably because my time
window is shorter than the other models
the other thing that i don't do is i
don't do smoothing
now i know that both the economist and
538 do smoothing as well i've got a very
abrupt transition
so the economist in particular when it's
working out it's uh the po the path
between points it uses a smoothing
algorithm which i don't use
so my model is much more susceptible to
swings here
and i've done that deliberately because
of what happened in 2016
is because i'm trying to capture uh
those kind of swings in voter behavior
the problem is it will give my model
more variability
than the other models as a question of
who's right
i don't actually know how you could do
that other than the final forecast
right because right now you know no
election has been held
and if my model is different from the
economists is different from
nate silver's it's a question of who
who's right
right so we can't really tell right now
what all we can tell is at the end of
the process where we end up and
my suspicion is that we might actually
end up all in the same place
right so whose model was right during
the election campaign i don't know and
i'm not entirely sure how you would
work that out frankly to be honest
uh we can have a look at the election
models by state
right so this is where the 95 confidence
intervals comes in and i think we asked
about
uh georgia hopefully i remember that
correctly
right so this is a bit of a mess so let
me clean it up let me turn off the 95
confidence intervals and turn off the
poles so here we have the democratic
and the republican votes as well so if i
put if i turn on the opinion poles
that we've got so you can see how my
algorithm is basically doing its
uh aggregation of the poles if you have
a slightly different aggregated model
you'd end up with a slightly different
result
if i hover over the polls it will
actually tell you who the polls are
um the democratic and the republican
percentages and whatever
but note there's tons of outliers and
this this is just one of the features of
opinion polling when you've got lots of
polls
loads of outliers so if i put on the 95
confidence intervals you can see that
all
you know basically although there's
about a percentage point difference
between the candidates and i have biden
leading uh in georgia
frankly it's within the 95 confidence
interval right
so i i wouldn't call that a certain
result by any means
right so my model is a little bit more
responsive than other people's i think
with a little bit more smoothing maybe
it would be
you know it would go either way but
there's a lot of states that are really
close right now okay so that all it
would take is one or two poles to flip
them and that's what you see in my model
as you see the discontinuities
okay john commented that smoothing feels
like it should
just be a user toggle able preference
um as you say it doesn't really matter
or
could you use an a b test smooth
versus a not smooth and see which
generates more page views
oh yeah i suppose you could um so
i i've just chosen i've used pandas for
this and i've used
i've you know just straight out linear
interpol interpolation
the reason is i wasn't sure what's the
best model of
you know if you were to in effect you're
not making this smooth what you're
trying to do is model what's going on
out there
and it's not clear to me that a smooth
model is preferable to
a more linear model so i don't know so i
could actually if i was
trying to get clicks for this i could
maybe put this on a website and have
maybe something where you could
choose different smoothing algorithms
and actually that's not a bad idea
actually i could change the smoothing
algorithm so you could have a look at
how it affects the results
right not not crazy and in fact i like
the idea of doing an a b
tester i could have maybe this is a
website where you click away
and see whether people prefer a smooth
view or my very harsh
linear view so i i was a physicist and i
know that this kind of harsh linear view
is not
representative of the physical world but
then i'm not sure whether a
smoother approach is actually more
accurate i
seriously need to do some research work
about that and i'm not sure a lot has
been published
there are two questions about the types
of data you use or data
first is from sebastian about do you
ever use senate race polls to predict
the general presidential election
for example south carolina race is
pretty close this year
would that impact your forecast for the
presidential race
no but um so actually you raised some
very good points there
so i don't i only use state level
opinion poll data
i don't use anything else uh senate
races i don't know
so i've tried to stay within the science
here right
and i don't know what that says about
you know adding in a state level for a
a senate race or a house of
representative race whether to add that
data in or not
i don't know if that would help i'd have
to play around with it and see
i'd also have to have a look to see what
was in the literature about using those
other data sources as a predictor
however there is a more general point
uh both nate silva's model and the
economist model another big difference
between my model as well
is that they use national results
to modify the state level results so for
example let me choose a state where i
don't think there'd been any opinion
polls
okay why am i okay there have been there
are a couple of states where there
haven't been maybe montana that hasn't
been
good grief okay so anyway let's just
take uh wyoming right
so i've only been four opinion polls in
wyoming right
let's imagine that there was only one
and it was an outlier
right obviously you would get a skewed
result the idea here is
that you take national opinion poll
results and you modify the state results
by the national results so let's say
that i didn't have
any opinion polls for for wyoming the
idea is that i would modify the voter
data of the 2016 data by the national
results to get what i believe
is a sense of what's going on based on
national data
so the idea here is that in wyoming and
maybe alaska and hawaii and
whatever other states that that don't
have many opinion polls
that you can model the changes in
behavior in those states in the absence
of opinion polls
by the national data and that's
something that nate silva does
so if you go and you have a look at his
opinion polls
and you have a look at some of the
states that don't have many opinion
polls like wyoming
you'll see that he has much more
variability in his model
and that comes from including the
national data
now i don't know whether to include that
or not and
what i'm in two minds about so when it's
it's obviously it's a data set that has
relevance right it is asking about the
election but then to voters in wyoming
or montana or
or massachusetts or or any other state
do they would you expect them to follow
the national trend
and that's not clear to me that you
would right so i'm not i mean two minds
whether
to include it or not most other modelers
have
and that's another one of the reasons
why it could well be between my models
uh you know nick silver's model and mine
it could well be that maybe he's seeing
a slight national difference which is
moderating some of those results in
favor of one candidate or another and i
don't have that moderating factor here's
the other question
uh there's actually an internal
conversation going on
while you're speaking um the other
question was
have we considered typical election day
stuff like weather
so for example a giant northern storm
thundering through the midwest from
minnesota to philadelphia could dump
turnout
and in this internal conversation um
there was actually articles posted where
uk parliament looked into the effect of
weather and daylight hours and elections
and
it doesn't seem like there's there was
no basically no correlation between the
weather and turnout
according to stephen fisher who's a
associate professor
at oxford okay yeah i i've heard that
i don't know there are other factors
election day factors um
you know the idea is that maybe in the
uk uh conservatives benefit from
better weather i i thought all kinds of
craziness as well i've not really seen
the data
to support or deny that um
so this is based on the pineapple data
and you know it obviously does not
factor into weather
pieces as well a true election model
might
include things like weather and a few
other bits and pieces as well
and maybe even the availability of
polling stations frankly
um but those yes it might be worth doing
i i would definitely have a look at the
data before you include it though
i think the last comment comes from eric
about how gelman uses
state to inform state 2. the idea that
michigan
oh yeah wisconsin i think pennsylvania
might swing together he calls this out
as a big delta between his model
and 538s and
cities that as a reason for our site
sorry sites that has a reason for
greater tales in the 538 scenarios
yeah so that's an interesting piece i'm
just gonna that's a really interesting
right so when i showed you the generator
polynomial right a while back and what
that's it's
suggesting is that uh all of the states
are independent
but there's a question are they really
and the idea that you know these guys
have is that
groups of states are influenced by one
another and don't necessarily act
independently of one another
so you may well have states in a group
of very conservative states or
group of very liberal states and they're
influenced by one another
and they tend to vote in the same way so
it's a coupling effect that's going on
um i've heard about this i don't know
i i think it's a difficult thing to
model the problem with modeling this
kind of stuff is that you don't have a
very big data set
you've got elections uh presidential
elections every four years and things
change
so your data's quite sparse to draw any
conclusions
it wouldn't surprise me if if there's
some kind of coupling going on
i don't include it in my model but i've
heard of it yeah
there's another question from john is uh
are you able to back test how well this
model design would have performed by
simulating its forecasts on historical
elections
yes so i'm able to do that to go back to
2016 and 2012 data
for this particular iteration of the
model i haven't done it because i ran
out of time to do it
the other reason for having some issues
with going back in time
is the data set and i'm going to
summarize in a little while and tell you
some of the things that i have to do
um the problem is that my polling data
for 2020 is in a different format from
2016.
right the 2012 data in the 2016 data
i've i've got comes from
the pulser api which is data in a
certain format and then next silvers is
in a different format and even things
like that
munging of the data to get it all to
work together involves quite a lot of
effort frankly
it is possible to go back to earlier
elections
uh 2008 and eve even back into the early
1990s
if you are an academic and you have
access to certain academic libraries of
election results
so the ropa center for example has a
library of
polling going back you know 50-plus
years but you have to be an accredited
academic to get hold of that data set
and i'm not i'm just some guy off the
streets
okay any other questions no i think that
was it so far
okay so i'll go to the last tab here
which is the poll viewer right so you
can actually view
the underlying opinion polls for that
state so here's the ohio polls and what
you can do you know
if there's a lot of them which there are
here you can narrow the range
shift things around a little bit we can
look at another state but let's look at
georgia
and there we go you know you can see the
polls for georgia and the other states
as well
all right so that's silkworm let's go
back into presentation mode
okay i want to talk about the software
architecture for this so for those of
you who are interested in building
business intelligence apps based on
python
this is the piece of the talk that will
interest you
it's 100 browser-based user interface
100
object-oriented python it uses a model
view controller architecture or
actually rather a variation of that it's
entirely
if you were to build a business
intelligence app using python
this is the approach that you would take
and it would look very much like it and
i'll tell you how i know that in a
second
uh the library the visualization library
is bokeh
uh the library is generally used to
bokeh pandas and umpi saipai and a few
others basically all the usual suspects
um so if you're going to build an
application like this
from scratch and use the model view
controller architecture
that follows a patent and if you're
going to use bokeh widgets
to implement stuff with drop-down boxes
and menus and buttons and
charts and all those things they all
follow a patent as well
and there are callbacks in there as well
so given the fact that the
callback functions and the widgets
follow a pattern
and model view controller follows a
pattern can't you just
automatically generate this stuff right
if it all follows the same pattern
why can't you just generate it
automatically you can
right so i have written for my employer
i've written
a uh a tool which will you start with a
json file
and from which adjacent file is on the
right hand side for this project
and from it you can automatically
generate an application with widgets
and it will actually run and show you
the widgets so you get a sense of
okay it's not connected to the data
source but you can see the relative
position of the widgets to one another
and you get a sense of whether you've
got the right widgets and the right
controls or not
so it generates the model view
controller framework all of the tabs
that you saw
all of the widgets the code is pep 8
compliant completely
it's runnable unfortunately it doesn't
fully lay out the
gui i'm working on some ideas to get
that done
and there's no automated way of dragging
and dropping components onto a canvas to
generate code
but the point with this automatic code
generation piece
is that you can focus on the value add
and not the tedious work of
wiring up the components right so in the
future what i intend to do is to
complete the widget coverage in
bokeh for automatic code generation i
also intend to do something about
including layout
so i can automate the layout a little
bit if possible auto generate
sphinx documentation right i can do that
i can lay the stubs for that and auto
generate the project you just haven't
done it
and what i would like to do is to get to
a state
where you can have a visual basic like
interface where you can drag and drop
components onto
a canvas and auto generate the whole
application from that that's what i'm
working towards
it's going to take a long time to get
there but i i think i can see
i can see what the result would be so
some commentary on this
all right i'm going to talk about my
experience of using python to generate
business intelligence like applications
so this thing that i've showed you today
is a hobby
right it's something that about every
four years i kind of wake up and i do
some playing around with
my day job is a senior director i have
teams of people report to me
and i've taken advantage of that to have
the teams
build business intelligence apps using
python the reason for doing it
is you know the data scientists know
python they don't know tableau and they
don't know some of these other tools
like click
for example so i'm taking advantage of
the existing skill set that i have
available
to me to go and build applications used
by the more general business
so in terms of functionality it compares
very well to
uh to tableau and click security
definitely is a non-issue
scalability works very well as well so
it definitely competes with those
business intelligence apps
using this approach but there are
knowledge barriers to entry here so a
lot of data scientists
aren't familiar with callbacks and ui
programming
and again although i've tried to
automate that away i haven't quite got
there yet so realistically to do this
you have to train your data scientists
a little bit in how to use callbacks
ginger 2 which is a templating piece
a lot of data scientists know it some
don't but then it's
we're going to use a lot more of this in
the future but still
given all these factors it is still very
labor intensive compared to using
tableau and click to build an
application like the silkworm
application i've showed you
probably a factor of two or three times
longer frankly
the manual layout is very difficult it's
quite difficult to do and things like
data table data sliders and file inputs
those are very effort intensive widgets
to get right
and in my code generation i've tried to
flesh them out i've still got a ways
more to go
with this as well but the whole goal is
to reduce the cost of building python
based business intelligence apps
using the approach that i've told you
speed of development i'm hoping to get
that down from a factor of two or three
slower
to something that's maybe one and a half
to twice as slow
right but again if i had to be if i had
tableau developers and click developers
i would use them but i don't
i well i have one i have a but i do have
everybody on the team knows python so
it's easier to use that skill set to
generate this kind of application
all right so some lessons learned and
what's next
so what's next so the us prudential
election for the silcon project
the error model i need to get right i
haven't taken into account
these systemic biases i need a good way
frankly of of including them in the
model
nobody's asked about bayesian um it i
have a very basic
version of bayesian in the model and the
previous version i had something more
sophisticated
i think i probably need a more
sophisticated bayesian model i suspect
that night silver
has one which is why his model is
different from mine why i think it's a
bit smoother as well and he doesn't have
the violent variations that i do
i think i need to put in a better
bayesian model maina nebraska
now nate silva definitely treats mainer
nebraska with a congressional district
method i don't i need to include those
as well and there are enough polls
in the different congressional districts
for maine and nebraska to produce a
result
um the pole filtering well just doing
this manually is awful
and i've done it in python code i really
should do it in schema to take it out of
the code
uh adjacent schema or something i've
just got to figure out a better way of
doing it
i also need to normalize all of this
data all of the 2012 data the 2016 data
and the 2020
2020 data and put it into some sql
database
it's not normalized at the moment which
makes multiple
looking multiple elections a bit
difficult
beyond this a u.s election forecasting
looking at the synod and the house this
approach would work
because there's no electoral college for
those places it's actually simpler
i could use this model well okay
it would be difficult to use this
approach in countries with multi-party
democracies like the uk
or ireland or germany it is a
much much harder problem is orders of
magnitude more difficult right and i
could talk about why that's harder
the us is almost a perfect country to do
this kind of modeling
because you've got two parties and
plenty of money for enough
uh rather for enough opinion polls and
you've only got 51 states including
washington dc to model
right so it's a lot simpler to model
than other countries
an electoral fraud if anybody asks we
can talk a lot more about electoral
fraud i've got quite a bit to say about
that
but before i just say largely it's
non-existent
right but there have been organized
efforts for example in north carolina
um i think i have found ways of
uh that i think there are ways of
detecting electoral fraud which we can
talk about later
right so some lessons learned here
polling is hard
so i've worked in a lot of organizations
where they want to do
opinion polls either opinion policies
their customer base or hr wants to poll
employees and i feel like getting up off
my table and giving people a good
slap when they say it right because i
don't think there's any appreciation of
just how
difficult this is it's usually the
people who are most enthusiastic about
running polls are the people with the
least experience
so polling is hard
also some more general lessons here
generally you need to understand how
data is collected
i was very fortunate that i had an
experience as a market research street
interviewer
i knew that uh basically random sampling
does not exist
but if i hadn't had that experience i
would be tempted to take the textbook
approach which would be wrong
so i just urge everybody uh you know it
may be the more junior people on the
call here
that when you're analyzing a very large
data set understand especially internet
data understand how that data was
collected
up secondly you can't fix fundamentals
so the 2016 data was fundamentally
broken because it didn't take into
account education
there is no way of going back and
retroactively fixing that data
and no way during the 2016 election you
could have detected it well you might be
able to detect it but you certainly
couldn't fix it
right and in fact the um literary digest
example is a classic case of how
basically size alone isn't enough and if
you have the wrong methodology no matter
what the size of your sample is going to
get
you going to give you the wrong result
the other piece take away that with a
few honorable exceptions the statistics
books and
courses are wrong they talk about random
sampling and they talk about other ways
of combining polls
which don't work in practice okay
now i'm going to finish up by giving a
quote from george box a famous
statistician and it's really about
humility right now i'm presenting these
results
i am fully aware that they might be
wrong
i had the experience of giving a similar
talk four years ago
where i stood up and i very confidently
predicted a hillary clinton victory
right so that's taught me a little bit
of humility as well the model is what
the model is and it is susceptible to
problems and it makes its predictions
all of these models are me nate silva
sam wang the economist
everybody is subject to error and that's
the same for every data scientist if
you're producing a model you are subject
to error and you might well get it wrong
so there's a little bit of humility that
i learned four years ago which hopefully
i've
continued forward with so let me end
with a quote from george box
all models are wrong some are useful
okay so we'll move into some more
general questions here uh for those of
you who want to link to me i put it i
put it in the chat maybe it's been lost
because i heard the chat's quite active
um here's some image credits they're all
from open source sources and i have to
acknowledge them
to stay compliant with the licensing and
there we go so
i will take some questions
one came in about uh why is it easier to
predict popular vote outcome
does it change the approach oh
no so the reason is that uh if you're
you're looking at a uh large scale
you're looking across the u.s there's
lots and lots of uh
national popular vote survey so it's
just the volume of
of opinion polls is greater so for
example
you might have a national opinion survey
that's run every two or three days
whereas in even in a state like florida
there might be a week between opinion
polls
right so it's the frequency of the data
in fact i did do an opinion poll post
where i talked about what was wrong in
2016 and i did actually download
the opinion poll national opinion poll
data for 2016 to play with it
i could see that the number of data
points was really quite large
right and it's very frequently surveys
as well so it's actually
you've got a much richer data set to
play with so you can make
better forecasts using it
yeah we might have to have a countdown
you know that or there are no questions
right
right so guys um maybe i've just stunned
everybody uh
by yapping away but uh if you have
questions
oh what am i right okay
so um so let's let's put out the
question first
uh eric asked what are users doing with
the
business intelligent apps your team
delivers what kinds of judgments are
they making
okay i am going to have to um
full back uncomfortably confidentiality
here right so it's an internal app
i what i will say about the app is it
presents a view of the internal data so
this is it's a
large data set orders of magnitude
bigger than the data set that we're
talking about here today
it presents summary views of the data
to enable diagnosis at the account level
and other levels of problems and of
trends in the data set as well
so it's very much a chart based view of
the data
that there's different plots that you
can look at a categorical data
time-based data other bits and pieces as
well so
it's it's a chart based the systems are
chart-based
there's a couple of drop-down boxes and
data tables and other bits and pieces in
there as well
but all of them are to do with data and
data quality and
looking at results and trends of data as
well so if you'd like
it's an active very typical business
intelligence data
piece i can't be more specific than tell
you that it's to do with
uh finding problems in the data and
finding trends in the data that's as
specific as i could be i'm afraid
john asks do you have any plans to open
source your business intelligence
generator
or if that's not currently possible
would you like to make it happen
so i would like to make this happen i
have had a chat with my employer about
this
so we might actually do this i don't
know if there's anybody interested
in this is a project taking it forward
uh i think it's something that
if multiple people worked on it it could
make a difference
right we could actually make some
progress got a little bit of cleanup to
do on this as i think i implied i got a
bit of clean up to do
with it there's some things that not
quite right but once those things are
done
um it will actually work pretty well in
fact it
works well it just doesn't work well
enough um
i think what i would like to in an ideal
world i would like to open sources i
would like to get a group of
people together to work on this and what
i would like to get
is if my vision is to have something
like visual basic you know we had you
know 25 years ago 20 years ago we could
drag and drop things onto a canvas
i very much love to get to that and i'd
love to get the code generated behind
the scenes
to to do that and then leave us with
basically wiring up the business logic
i don't i can see that all the
technology exists to do it
uh we just there's nobody actually doing
it
there's another question on are your
users working with point estimates
or measures or do intervals come into
play for them
i guess this is to do with my uh work
applications
so uh let me talk so a lot of this is
charting trends over time and different
views over time
different kind of time periods uh there
are some uncertainties in the
measurements so we do have 95
confidence intervals some of the other
things that we do
is uh we look at whether uh data follows
the statistic of the distribution types
it should so that for
certain types of data it should follow
certain distributions and i can't be any
more specific than that i'm afraid
you can look for deviations from that
and some of the work that we're doing is
actually looking for statistically
significant deviations
from that that data set so i'm not
entirely sure if i've answered your
question eric but
i i can't really be that more specific
i'm afraid it's all confidential and
proprietary and stuff
i think i'm going to start a countdown
oh no
oh well eric thanks you for uh your
response
um oh he also wondered about the
presence of stats in
business intelligence apps okay so i'm
gonna have to
come a little bit clean about my
background i used to work for a business
intelligence
company right it's
what they tend to have is a fairly
limited library of
uh analysis functionality right all of
these tools right
no one has the kind of strength and
depth that r
and python have right in these propriety
models with the exception of the math
works right
which is different kettle official
together um so
i i think if you really want detailed
statistics in these models you've got
two choices
right so one is that you auto generate
the data beforehand
and you put it into database tables and
you use tableau and click to query the
results
and you offer the user options from a
limited set of options
or you enable some full-on statistical
analysis
in which you'd have to use go to bi
tools
built with python or or r for example
so if you really want that firepower if
you want a user interface that has that
statistical firepower in my view
you have to go to these applications and
that's one of the reasons why
i'm playing around with this data set in
the way that i've done it to figure out
what i can do
so this is a hobby as i've said but it's
kind of bleeding over into the business
world as well and my sense is that i
want to be able to produce
um business intelligence apps using
python a lot faster
so i can use the resources on the team
better and to use some of the
statistical firepower on this and the
other general purpose programming
structures that are available in python
great
going on okay everyone
just a final comment here um if you want
to link on linkedin i'm open i'd like to
do this conversation i talked about this
i will
blow out this some more if you want
detail about this
he asked about electoral fraud i was
kind of laying this out i got some in
well hopefully interesting things to say
about electoral fraud again
i don't think it's something that's a
reality right not in the way that it's
being painted
uh there are certainly no armies of
people committing fraud in the united
states just no evidence for it
i can tell you where you can go and find
data about electoral fraud if you're
interested
so but nobody is unless you want to ask
in the dying seconds
um that's it but i'm open to a link on
linkedin and if you want to talk
or uh you're interested in hearing more
i could go and
paste a few more post a few more blog
posts and describe things in more detail
if you want
yeah thank you so much mike for coming
and speaking with us today and
having a very timely topic given the
upcoming elections
and i want to thank everyone for you
know having this hearty conversation and
having a real you know
q a um in the middle of the talk at the
end
and sticking through with us we hope to
see you at
our next event
and yeah don't forget about pi data
global
someone actually joked about having um
your project as a pi data global sprint
[Laughter]
with a bi stuff if i could get a company
to uh
to agree i would be open to that
great thank you everyone good night
everyone thank you